ultimately the point and I want to drill
this into every politician's head every
businessman's head the answer to our
economy the solution to our economy is
not in the economic it's not in the
money it's in the productivity of
devices and technology so yeah yeah and
and that's another tragedy of the
post-covet economy and and you know I
don't care what your party is Joe Biden
winning we started again to move away
from that and uh under Trump we went
back to good Purdue you know good Goods
producing uh productivity was obviously
increasing
it you can kind of get away too with
having it and I don't want to encourage
debt but if you make things the world
needs and you are the leader of that you
get grace period if your entire economy
which is uh you know uh your your
strength is based on the Petro dollar
and you're not making it enough it's too
expensive your that's ridiculous uh that
that puts you in a bad way we may buy
ourselves some time being something that
somebody needs this is this